[Musique]
aujourd'hui l'explosion des appareils
numériques fait qu'on a une quantité de
données à la fois stockées échangées qui
est devenu faire la mineuse les chiffres
donnent le tournis aujourd'hui on estime
que en 2025 on attendra 175 états octet
de données ce qui est tout simplement
énorme alors tout cela nécessite
évidemment des data center où sont
stockées ces données-là et ses
datacenter aujourd'hui arrive un petit
peu à la limite de ce qu'ils sont
capables de faire puisqu'il consomme à
chaque fois de la terre agricole la
terre utile pour être construits et puis
il nécessite également de l'eau pour les
refroidir et d'électricité dans quantité
importante pour les faire fonctionner
donc tout cela on s'aperçoit que petit à
petit la multiplication des datacenter
donc et des données va avoir un impact
environnemental non négligeable sur
notre planète
les molécules l'adn stock aujourd'hui
déjà des données ce sont les données de
notre génome humain donc on estime que
si elles sont capables de pouvoir ce
qu'est notre génome humain elles sont
aussi capables de stocker d'autres
données que devenu réalité les archives
nationales ont rentré leurs premières
capsules de dn dans leurs armoires de
faire ce qu'ils appellent à un mois de
faire notamment la déclaration des
droits de l'homme et du citoyen et puis
la déclaration des droits de la femme et
de la citoyenne qui ont également été
mises sur adn et qui pour l'exemple
seront stockés un certain nombre
d'années voire des centaines voire des
milliers d'années l'autre force de l'adn
c'est sa concentration informationnel
aujourd'hui on peut mettre énormément de
données sur un très petit volume on
estime aujourd'hui qu'on peut mettre les
données de la terre entière dans
l'équivalent d'une demi salle dans une
cuisine qui est aussi très intéressant
c'est cette possibilité de le lire à
long terme aujourd'hui on sait lire des
adn de la préhistoire on sera aussi lire
ce constat qu'aujourd'hui sur l'adn dans
des milliers d'années aujourd'hui à des
blocages la stga choix diène évolué dans
le bon sens et énormément de progrès qui
sont faits en revanche les phases de
synthèse et de séquençage sont des
phases assez difficile elles sont
onéreuses elles sont chronophages et
aujourd'hui il faut se donner encore un
certain nombre d'années pour pouvoir y
arriver et que ce soit concurrentiel
avec les données aujourd'hui déstockage
que nous avons aujourd'hui nous avons
des laboratoires de recherche très
performants nous avons un tissu
académique très très important nous
avons des start up qui sont pionnières
en france sur ces domaines là j'ai bon
espoir que
le stockage sur dien dans les années à
venir prennent encore de l'ampleur nous
suivons de près ce type de projet
puisque la partie des tic il va falloir
légiférer sur ce type de technologie il
faut tout de suite mettre des limites
sur ce qu'il est possible de faire et ne
pas faire typiquement dans des dossiers
qui vont nous occuper sur les cinq dix
quinze prochaines années lorsqu'on dit
que parfois on légifère que sur des
choses qui sont passés c'est important
aussi de pouvoir anticiper sur des
projets de telle ampleur